مره صدر عن محكمه محليه وهناك همم فتره لي
الاستئناف ولكن امام اوغلو والان يتحدث
الى انصاره المتجمعين امام مبنى بلديه
اسطنبول يتحدث وكانه منتصر وليس همم كمان
حكم عليه
بعامين وسبعه شهور وايضا همم المنع
السياسي هو يتحدث الان هو كانه منتصر
ويعيد الاذان في تركيا الى عقدين من الزمن
عندما حكم على الرئيس اردوغان همم حينما
كان ايضا رئيسا للبلديه حكم عليه بالسجن
وخرج من السجن نجما سياسيا تمكن من تحقيق
الكثير سواء على المستوى المحلي ومن ثم
السيطره على همم الحكومه والسلطه في تركيا
لاكثر من عقدين وبالتالي هي ربما ذات
الصوره تتكرر الان الحكم الذي صدر ان وصل
الى المرحله القطعيه عزيزه هذا يعني امام
مغلوسيال اول من رئاسه البلديه ومن تم من
الرئاسه حزب او من عضويه حزب الشعب
الجمهوري المعارض وبالتالي هو محظور من
العمل السياسي
لعامين وسبعه شهور يا فتره الحكومه صادر
بحقه ما يعني انه لن يتمكن من الترشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه وهو كان مرشحا محتملا
ومنافسا شرسا في الانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد
ان تمكن من هزيمه حزب العداله والتنميه
والفوز بمرتين في انتخابات رئاسه البلديه
هنا في اسطنبول عام 2019 في الجوله الاولى
كان الفرق في الاصوات بينه وبين همم مرشح
حزب العداله والتنميه اكثر بقليل من
13,000 صوت وعده الانتخابات وهنا وصف امام
مغلق لجنه الانتخابات
بالغباء ومن ثم واجهه هذه الدعوه القضائيه
لكنه فاز في الانتخابات بعد فتره وجيزه
ولكن بفارق تجاوز
770,000 صوت يعني انه تمكن من تحقيق فارق
اكبر بعد ان اعيد في الانتخابات ربما هي
الان فرصه للامام اوغلو لي يسطع نجمه بشكل
اكبر انتمكن من الاستئناف انت مكنا من
الحصول على البراءه من هذه القضيه وربما
هذا ما سيسعى اليه سيكون مرشحا اقوى في
الرئاسيات ان ترشحها في طبيعه الحال
باختصار
المعارضه على المستوى السياسي
هو قرار سياسي وليس قرارا قضائيا همم رئيس
حزب الشعب الجمهوري تحدث وقال انما جره
وقتل وجريمه قتل القانون وان القرار صدر
من القصر الرئاسي في انقره احمد داوود وهو
ايضا تحدث عن ان هذه القضيه هي قضيه
سياسيه زعيمه الحزب الجيد جاءت الى
اسطنبول من انقر لتعلن تضامنها مع اكرم
امام اوغلو وبالتالي احزاب المعارضه واقفه
وداعمه للامام اوغلو في هذه القضيه شكرا
جزيلا لك الاسد موف مراسف رزان كاتر عفوا
في اسطنبول